Hmm.
The so called liberal argument,
which is probably more liberal today
than it has been in many,
many decades.
Um,
you know,
they argue that we should have equal
equality.
Everybody should be equal.
We should all make the same amount of
money.
We should all have the same assets and
well,
I don't believe that.
I think that's fundamentally inimical to
free market capitalism.
I think that's a kind of Soviet,
uh,
East Europe,
you know,
old communist socialist model that has
never worked you,
you can't make anybody everybody equal.
They tried to redistrict it,
redistribute income and wealth rather
than increase it.
Um,
my credo here is instead of making the
economic pie smaller and handling
smaller pieces to everyone,
let's make the pie bigger and get
everybody a larger piece.
And I think history has proven really
since the fall of Soviet communism that
that model of income leveling is a bad
model.
It's a mild does work.
It took seven years for the Soviets to
felt fall,
but they fell.
And China,
for example,
the other big communist country,
I won't say that they've fallen,
but they've changed their economy.
It's now much more of a market oriented
economy in my judgment.
Markets distribute goods,
market set prices,
and if there are free opportunities
inside markets,
that's how people who work hard will do
well.
And I think the ethos in America is to
work hard.
That's always been where we are.
In other words,
we all start at the same beginning.
The starting line is the same.
By law and tradition,
we should be prejudice,
free,
color free,
gender free,
whatever.
We all have the same legal starting
line,
but that doesn't mean we all finish at
the finish line at the same.
And I think that's human nature.
So we talk about this in the book and in
particular as you asked about,
uh,
tax policy,
taxing rich people at high confiscatory
rates has never worked in this country.
It's outside of our tradition.
It's been tried a couple of times.
Um,
FDR tried it 1930s and it didn't work
and the economy was no better in the
late thirties than it was when he took
over in 1932.
Um,
the war spending did help,
but the great new deal experiment failed
the great times of prosperity in this
country.
It's so when we lower tax rates and we
shrank government,
we put government in a lesser position.
I'm a believer in the private sector.
The government does not run the economy.
We run the economy.
So you go back and look at some
unbelievable prosperity periods like the
post civil war period.
Unbelievable.
The 1920s,
unbelievable prosperity,
the 1960s,
unbelievable.
The 1980s and nineties,
fantastic economic growth.
Those all have some common
characteristics and usually they include
low marginal tax rates.
So you keep more of what you earn.
That's a reward for your work and
investment and entrepreneurship.
Uh,
less government,
fewer regulations.
That doesn't mean no government.
It doesn't mean no regulations.
I'm for a safety net,
but it means at some point you go too
far and you're strangling businesses.
You're strangling small businesses.
And that's who I'm really worried about.
So that's my basic argument.
John F.
Kennedy,
to get right to the chase in this book,
John F Kennedy's tax cut legacy has been
lost.
It's a very strange story and that's one
of the reasons why Brian Dimitra rich
and I wrote this book.
Kennedy was the first post World War II
supply side tax cutting president.
He was the first Eisenhower wouldn't do
it.
And the 1950s,
despite certain urban legends,
the 1950s where allows the economy three
recessions,
and in eight or nine years,
Kennedy knew
having one by a cat's whisker against
Nixon.
Kennedy knew that he had to grow the
American economy at 5% a year.
That was his target.
Nixon didn't go there and Kennedy never
really told us in the 1960 election how
he was going to grow at five,
but he said,
this is what we're going to do.
And then he went back and forth with his
advisors in 1961 and 1962 the first step
he made was one I disagree with.
He had a lot of government spending lots
and lots of government spending,
safety net spending,
infrastructure spending,
you name it,
which is liberal academic advisors.
Um,
uh,
suggested to him that was their idea,
spend,
spend and leave tax rates high.
You know,
at the top tax rate was 91%.
It's inconceivable.
So you earn an extra dollar,
you get 9 cents,
but government gets the rest.
That's a big number.
So anyway,
make a long story short or at least this
part of the story.
Short,
Kennedy had several Republicans in his
cabinet.
This is an interesting side note,
but very important for today.
One of them was a guy named Douglas
Dillon who came from a famous banking
family.
Uh,
just like get Kennedy.
He has as much money as JFK,
his father and his banking guy and owned
the vineyard in south of France.
He was Eisenhower's under secretary of
state.
Anyway,
Kennedy puts him in the top tier
Treasury Department and Dylan makes the
argument that the liberals were wrong
and instead we should give men and women
more opportunities,
more rewards,
more incentives to grow the economy.
If you get paid more,
you're likely to work more.
Or if the tax rate is lower on
investment for a new business,
if you are rewarded with higher pay
after tax,
you're going to be rejuvenated.
You're going to get out there and go for
the gold.
And that hasn't been happening since
World War II hadn't happened in the
1950s.
Uh,
it was just throughout one number for
it.
It's in that book at 91% tax rate.
So as I said,
you make a,
you make an extra dollar,
you get 9 cents,
right?
The government gets a 91 cents.
Now,
Ronald Reagan as a movie actor quit
acting because he decided 9 cents on the
dollar was not enough for him to
motivate him.
True Story.
Um,
Kennedy cut the top tax rate from 91 to
70.
So instead of taking home 9 cents on the
dollar,
you took home 30 cents on the dollar.
That's an over 200% increase.
And after tax income,
and Kennedy argued he was the pioneer
and I Reagan Kennedy,
that this will create opportunities and
incentives.
They'll get government out of the way.
It'll get people work at harder.
It'll get them to take risks to start
new companies.
Um,
a lot of new companies,
a lot of technology and silicon valley
stuff was started in the 60s,
uh,
after the Kennedy tax cuts.
That was his argument.
And then 20 years later,
the top rate was at 70,
and Reagan cut it the 28 and two steps,
1981,
1986,
28.
So now instead of getting 30 cents on
the dollar,
you got 72 cents on the dollar.
It's about 145% increased.
That's what I call reward.
That's a basic economic principle.
We don't work to finance the government,
we don't work.
Uh,
unless we are compensated for the hard
work,
we might go on welfare,
but that's not going to necessarily help
the country.
It helps the poor.
But we want less poverty.
We want more opportunity.
So give us more after tax income.
That's what Kennedy did.
It's called an incentive.
That's what Reagan did and it's called
and a Saturday and both times it worked.
That's the thing.
Kennedy,
the Democrat,
a lot of people said he was a liberal
democrat.
Actually.
He was not.
He was very conservative.
But Kenny,
the Democrats using a Republican
treasury secretary,
Doug Dawn Reagan,
20 something years later,
the Republican,
okay,
who wound Democrats in Congress to get
his tax cuts through.
They presided over the best economic
decades postwar.
And it is not a coincidence that they
both were tax cutters and we can talk
about this later,
but they also wanted a steady and strong
reliable dollar as our currency.
But incentives matter.
The government does not run our,
our economy.
We run our economy as long as we are
properly rewarded for our efforts and
our entrepreneurship and Soviet Union.
The Soviets,
randy economy,
it was horrible,
horrible,
rampid poverty.
China is horrible.
East Europe,
horrible Latin America,
horrible.
And then came the free market revolution
and things picked up quite a bit because
people had more economic freedom.
And that's why I argue this,
uh,
I'm not even,
I'm not talking politics here.
I'm just talking straight out economics.
1970s Republicans and Democrats
destroyed the currency,
created double digit inflation and
raised taxes.
And the 70s were a horrible period of
economic growth.
We had 12 15% inflation twice.
The economy barely grew.
And then Reagan came in and change that.
And by the way,
just to make sure,
this is bipartisan.
Bill Clinton,
Democrat,
he did raise the income tax in his first
year,
but then he came back a few years later
and cut the capital gains tax,
which is a very important task for
investors and risk takers,
and he acknowledged that he raised
income taxes too much.
Clinton was also a free trader.
I wouldn't say Clinton was Reagan's
third term,
but he's pretty close to Reagan's third
term.
Unfortunately,
today,
the Democratic Party's hope,
hopefully,
hopefully lost.
They won't go through this.
They want to tax wealthy people.
They want to punish success.
It's not the way America does it.
It's not the way success is created.